even if we could cut all greenhouse gas  emissions today  the effects of climate change are  already here  so we need to do much more to adapt to  the consequences of climate change we  cannot avoid  the new eu adaptation strategy will help  us get there  by preparing for climate change we can  become more resistant to extreme weather  we need to improve our infrastructure  invest more in solutions from science  and nature help other countries to adapt  and learn from them too we want to do  more to protect people  livelihoods and nature in europe and  around the world  reducing risks for our planet and for  future generations  you